hey what's up guys my name is a chana
and welcome to episode 85 of game
programming this is the very first time
in the entire history of game
programming that I've put up a second
episode in one day
that's two episodes in one day and I did
that because we you asked we hit 300
likes in like what was it like some
ridiculous like less than 12 hours I
think which was absolutely ridiculous
and because of that you guys get in a
second episode today so if you want that
to happen again
make sure this video reaches 300 likes
and well I'll have to keep releasing
them to upset today like all week at
least so yeah anyway last time we took a
look at these these Wohlers here and the
floor and out of course the crumbled
kind of wall thing and today we're gonna
take a look at the player so this is
what the player looks like right now
qingchun oh and that's cool but the
thing is I don't know what the player
should look like okay this gonna be kind
of hard and what I should have done in
retrospect before I started recording
this he's probably just like tweeted out
or something and you know asking for
like a theme for the player because I
don't know what you guys kind of want
from this this isn't like a game that
I'm kind of making them for myself but
let's go to 32 by 32
let's not maintain the aspect ratio I
don't know what you guys kind of want
for the player so I'm just gonna go with
what I think looks cool and that's how
we're gonna do it that's how we're gonna
do business so we're gonna start in
paint.net and the only thing we're
really gonna do an After Effects has
probably add a bit of lighting and it's
really safe to add lighting to the
player because of course he's not gonna
be tiled at any point so what I did for
LOD him dare I actually made a pretty
good-looking player to be honest I'm
really quite happy with that but it was
kind of like a because it was because
the um I guess the theme was ten seconds
and that kind of correlates the time I
kind of made like a doctor who kind of
looking um character but obviously this
is this has nothing to do with ten
seconds or time so we're not going to do
that
but I still want to kind of give him a
suit probably like a black suit I think
that'll look cool
rather than heater no but I think some
ridiculous hair is in order because I
have some ridiculous hair in real life
so let's let's start so I like to do an
outline first so we've got 32 pixels to
work with so that's the Ralph size of
how big one pixel is we've got 30 we've
got 32 pixels to work with for the
player and I think we're probably gonna
be using all of them that's a that's a
lie obviously like I feel every pixel
here but if we grab some that's probably
that has a bit ridiculous if we grab
some there's gonna be a really fun
episode by the way as you can pop retail
if we grab some basis for this hair kind
of thing I don't want it to be a 2 out d
Society so not not don't want those not
don't want that hair being out at the
side too much and I think we could
probably do something like this play
around with that and if we come down
here you know maybe give him kind of
like a collar here and cause I'm gonna
run out of space here I hate this we
could make him kind of dwarf he couldn't
wait I don't know that kind of looks
good for games as well so some shoes
does look desert there's actually pretty
good cheese all right cuz we've gone for
a pixel arty kind of look I'm doing a
black and white for now by the way I'm
gonna change that in it soon sir
let's say yeah so he's got in our body
at the moment pretty much okay we can
get rid of some of this some we can
shift this up and I think we can shift
some of this down here and okay so
that's that's decent in terms of us
claim let's clean off some of this maybe
if his face and kind of here chin here
let's see what else here mm-hmm
just thinking okay so because we're
doing a bit of a suit let's make sure we
do a leather jacket open because that's
because that's cool and yeah
so it's a pretty cool you gotta admit
all right so we've got this going on
here we could probably do Oh a tie red
tie well that's a bit cliche isn't it
but let's do that anyway man it's gonna
be hard to do a tie here with only like
a few pixels that's a tie right yeah
but definitely gonna look up and be like
that is a tie it's the first thought I
was gonna come to the head arms well I
mean I guess we could probably just my
ass three arms and what are we gotta go
on yeah
man I hate working in low resolution
high resolutions pretty bad as well
because that gets complicated fast but
low resolution is low resolution isn't a
phone either so let's make sure that we
can say is shirt here and I think for
the caller yeah that's funny look it
looks looks like his head's got him
blasting off in an upward trajectory
here it's pretty funny but mmm let's
give him a beard as well beards are cool
on that okay let's play around with the
color off his hair so Brown I'm thinking
like a dark brown yeah um how's that
maybe a bit darker yeah again make sure
that why are they affecting this area
that's a pretty good color I think clear
up some of this for now I don't want
some that looks like a pretty solid
beard he's got going on there let's make
sure that this is symmetrical how we're
gonna do that I think it's going up like
that isn't it is that Matt's this much
like that that's three there and there
should be three years I got to shift
this this way let's give him some eyes I
think if we girly-girly eyes blue of
course
as eyelashes a way to black maybe that
should be this color that says that kind
of look like flowers he's a man let's
get rid of this is that look off Santa
what if he had a lot of people draw eyes
vertically my god he looks like a cat if
we do that what if you had huge guys man
that is some scary stuff
reminds me of the logo of reddit for
some reason right logo the alien that's
probably is that too wide gonna lose all
down his eyes maybe that is just okay I
will leave it at that leave it at that
but I was pretty cool
Norah's screw that says the chair no I'm
not I'm doing my little crap and let's
grab some his hair and kind of lower it
here make him look cooler I'll be could
break giving long hair okay maybe not
that wide though
manners guys prior you would not want to
mess with this guy there's like bald
spots on there
I can't make sure that he doesn't look
too ridiculous yeah so we need a setting
for this Durham way like for this entire
like game what's the storyline of this
game someone should really like write
write that out because that would be
interesting we kind of need a storyline
because then we could plan these things
instead of just drawing random
characters here and being like yeah that
looks cool
what if he had a great certain sort of
black and obviously a black shirt I'm
sorry I obviously i watch it they don't
work alright so the Hat the hair looks
ridiculous also the block of mouth and
he's got missing patches ahead yeah
we'll probably just grab another color
and make some highlights or something
soon oh that looks cool almost was like
a friend of mine
okay that's lower that sigh make that
like this let's give him some of those
the show will be surrounded and white in
white and I'll probably grab some hands
as well here
okay we got a we better make sure that
this is symmetrical here so he's
measuring 11 pixels across this should
be 12 pixels across yeah okay cool
that's good gives us a bit of room here
doesn't it but what have we screwed up
then I think I am so that's seven and
that is six okay so in that case wait
Pam this is 5 and this is make this 5 as
well but this is 5 as well not sure you
should be fine then okay let's just see
how this works and let's not forget this
little section here okay that looks
pretty good I think the gray suit works
better than the white side here this
kind of um I don't know better Sarah
here it kinda looks bland sorry if I'm
talking quietly by the way I just deeply
concentrated right now
okay this fate the thing we should wind
that up as well I wonder if that would
look better
okay how's that those shoes aren't very
cool are they okay so that is what
should we call this character let's give
him a um skin color here as well oops
that's my whiter probably okay eyes what
if we make one pixel eyes I don't think
that's not look too nice Oh kind of say
that wait a name as well
I mean King Chennai but we're name yeah
hilarious just like a Christmas train
away there we go how does he looks like
I don't know he looks like kind of looks
like um well Jesus but in a suit
wow this could be hilarious
let's see um just this white space here
it's a shirt but not really doesn't look
like a show okay also these arms these
um suit arms here
okay well that's nice I sounds
Carla's not looking to to cool hmm
dragony is too fat I don't know make him
a bit thinner
I didn't think what no that's why do it
then nothing that's good I think that's
good okay let's quickly grab the hair
here and maybe add a few highlights just
to make stuff more interesting that
looks [ __ ] as of course is my
drawing ability what if we were to
highlight like one side
nope okay doesn't matter this is fine
okay so that is I think we're gonna
probably leave it like that for now
let's uh let's fill in let's grab all
this whoops let's grab all this space
here and I should done this at the
beginning of course but if we grab all
this space here and the way are all the
white space and make it pink so that it
can be transparent in our game that'll
be great
okay so FF 0 0 FF and oops I forgot
about this oops
keep hitting shift instead of
controlling and paint on that that's it
doesn't do what you think it does okay
so that's our character right now don't
even know what you call him but that's
okay so let's let's go to where are we
where in rain and go resources textures
and sheets and well play up play up
front dot PNG this is a shade I'll just
leave it outside ashes okay so we've
done the front now let's do the back
it's gonna be a long episode that's
alright you guys seem to enjoy the long
episodes so I'm cool with that
let's I would've been doing file new 32
by 32 and let's grab this guy yeah
I'll pay him yeah all right so the back
is pretty easy to do we'll just get rid
of this essentially leave the hair we
need to get her to this as well
that's pretty is it it is so it's not
gonna be as easy but that's okay we'll
manage how do you think that's reckon
that's true just just a bit wide that's
why it doesn't look right I don't know I
guess we'll leave it at that that looks
pretty good we weren't doing a mission
just yet cuz that'll take way too long
oh we could buy like lifting one leg I
guess that's alright so this is playback
that took like 2 seconds mm-hmm ok let's
make another one and we'll paste in the
front again this is gonna be play aside
so this is gonna be a bit of a challenge
I think let's say the side
I guess this side would kind of look
oh man I have to learn how to draw okay
well it's probably gonna be thinner
since usually people are not cubes
probably make that eye a bit longer
that's the mouth right well technically
this should be like here
and as for this I think if we grab it
and in fact let's just delete this
section probably redraw it and if we
whoops come in here and I guess we'll
just do one leg right come on it's like
a sigil some reason maybe Daffy just me
okay so this this area here on looks
like a side so I might copy that and I
might delete this and I'll paste that
and kind of move it here just so we have
like a template to work off of man that
is that looks like it look like his head
is like on at right here it's just it's
just wonderful isn't it so I'll probably
move this entire thing over here he's
gonna have to be probably just to touch
water than that now it looks like he's
got a freaking um big stomach like a big
belly or something all the joys of this
maybe if we
oh we could just get I guess a lighter
gray honestly if you guys like if there
are some people in here that watch the
entire video like good work because this
is um I don't know I just could I don't
think I could imagine everyone watching
this entire video it's kind of um too
boring
right I'd say but it needs to be done
and bloody guys seem to want to see this
stuff so yeah I am
at your service
alright that's looking a bit better here
sorry about your hair bro we're just
having to Guerra get rid of some of it
okay
Special Agent Jenner is ready almost
what are this stuff that okay what do
you guys think um have to say oh wow no
that's all right
and let's save that as play up right and
then we'll copy and paste that into play
out left okay that's looking pretty good
right now I think now what we're
probably gonna do is make a quick shade
of that so let's say if we have if we
have four of these right now how many
how much animation do we want probably a
three frame animation for each so that's
a total of 12 frames we need three times
four so let's um so for one three times
four
hang on a minute we want three frames of
each right so that's 32 times 3 which is
96 yes nice X by 96 let's make a quick
grid here
I wonder if you just play this grid as
multiple like sizes sorry
32 okay that's a really nice color for a
grid
okay so now let's grab our fire wall
like really mess it up you guys probably
noticed I missed one so image canvas
size and we'll probably just make it one
wider so 128 grid there you go okay cool
so let's find our actual folder here and
going to resources textures and bring
out all of these guys so this will be
out right oh I never flipped it whoops
my bad so this is play right and what
can we play left because play lives okay
so what I was gonna do is just flip him
pretty much but that's going to be
interesting to ask that shouldn't be too
difficult
okay there you go
so now I'll take play up I save that not
play a left and add him to this laughs
okay cool and there we go oops
and then we got play a front here which
should be the first one which is away
he's out right now anyway and then play
it back which is a bad guy cool
so for animation I think if we just I
probably shouldn't
that's alright just thinking about the
ultratex lighting stuff
okay let's quickly squash these layers
here so all of them match medals and
copy and paste this remove them right
over here okay so for this guy
I think when he walks let's just lift up
one of his legs here
and I think latest rotate him kind of
round him so it's like he's oh what if
he was pointed forward like that so that
kind of looks like he just lost one of
his legs because they're up there to the
side normally so that's not great
okay that's fine if we lift it up one
more and if we lift his other hand as
well and my truffle up a bit of his
clothing yeah just to kind of sure that
he's actually walking yeah one off oops
okay one more
except this time we can simply flip him
and there you have it okay cool whoops
so now we have to do kind of the same
thing with I think we might want to fix
up his leg here yeah okay next guy all
right sir
same thing
I think we could make make and they can
walk like comically fast in the game or
something that way it would look okay
okay so what I do here March I guess I
kind of widened this area i widened this
area and crapped wrong arm come on Jonah
get into it okay I wasn't this and I
think that's it yeah
alright oops not freaking where's the um
that's not gonna help okay
um I think that's him flip this guy set
him back okay cool so we got a decent
animation here let's grab this guy pop
him down here so for this I think we
could probably animated a bit better and
leave his other foot down here
leave his other foot down here as normal
but this foot probably go out in front
or something I don't know
yeah or not
looks like he's growing something out of
his name I am pro at this I've got a
roach headed a bit in fact we can do it
here
fortunately painter that's not helping
with that
looks like K or something this is
awesomely fun
that's our character walk taking a walk
here well I guess technically his leg
should come out of here so we fix this
up make it look a bit better give it
short huh it's like trying to grow when
he takes walks
whatever I think that's all right my
stand is the protein lawyers Forrest's
price goes you guys probably tell
I was just thinking that wouldn't earth
am I gonna do for this one okay what if
we were to kind of bend his knee yes
it's not good
Oh
what is it we thought alike and wet done
that was easy
so let's see the other leg in front and
this lecture probably since this legs in
front did you probably go like this
there we go
cool and the best thing is we could
probably just use that too
I could probably just flip this and
everything will be all right
and look at that we have a pretty
awesome looking player let's save this
as in in sheets will call it player and
will come in here into After Effects
quickly and will import our player where
is he sheets player will import him
quickly and we'll just drag we'll drag
him into the new comp button and all I'm
going to do here is basically make the
problem with doing this is that I can't
globally light em I'll have to light
each separate one individually so we're
gonna have to create like twelve
compositions here so we'll just go
layout
sorry composition new composition 32 by
32 call it play out front a 1 or 0 of 1
and we'll grab player
grab his first one here and then let's
grab a new light and that should be good
okay cool let's make him a 3d layer and
oh yeah I forgot about the fact that Oh
see I should have done this first this
lighting because the pink is going to
cease to be pink
basically that's okay there we can fix
that later so I'll go new composition
again and play a front 2 which will be
the player but I should have some grid
lines in here this is going to be hard
is that Center yeah
okay and we'll make him a 3d layer copy
and paste that light and then I'm gonna
copy and paste this and go in your
composition and once again play out
front
that's back what am i doing I'm not even
naming these correctly let's do front
three
so we'll grab the light as well I
shouldn't have made the light there you
go
so I'll write this trend is to play a
back one play it front just play front
to composition your composition play out
front three grab these two elements here
copy and paste them into here move this
guy down - yeah
and of course move the light okay at a
lot of leverage well wait
cool so now we'll do all the time for
play out back to copy and paste these to
remove them let's make sure look we're
only moving plan to Baxter which is here
let's apply back to her done play out
back three areas
it's scented save that composition you
come play right one so halfway there
play a right one and make a new comp
play out right - it's pretty fun stuff
going on here player right three that's
left isn't that the entire thing was
left mm-hmm
brilliant whatever left three which is
here okay
player I guess go left now one
so we've switched we've forgotten what
right and left is apparently this is a
long episode as well like all right like
40 minutes right now and player left to
make sure we've moved just the play and
not the light as well because we don't
want the light to move at all and
finally last one player left three which
is really player right through but I am
stupid sometimes so I forgot that okay
now we can make a new composition called
play a sheet make it 128 by 96 and now
what we have to do is grab all these
player back things whatever okay
actually let's just grab the first three
the front let's set them out here as we
should
so one two three
and what I want to do is very soon as
will actually change the paint color to
be solid player left so the left oh well
we shouldn't have done the left now
let's do them later
let's do back it doesn't really matter
obviously we haven't actually said them
in the card yet so so we'll put the
first back one there the second back one
here and the third back one third back
one here and now we'll grab the that's
right so we'll grab the right ones now
because we screwed up our naming like
bosses not really like the opposite of
bosses two and three
all right and finally we'll grab but
left one left here and left three and
looks like we're done okay so now what
we should do is go to this pink so we
can probably do that just by there's an
effect called change to color if we pre
compose all of this in fact yeah for pre
compose status play us brights and add
the change to color thing we can change
from roughly this pink color to
something else here so we'll go hue
lightness and saturation and we'll
change it to be exactly an FF series or
FF alright and that will get rid of
that's actually perfect I think right
yeah that will get rid of all the old e
um what do you call it all the
background and give it this background
which is that good background so now
intention is we've added lighting to
this player guy to make him look just a
bit cooler so that um that's awesome
so let's actually just export this shade
so if we go to composition save frame as
file and then we can choose the file
type we want probably a PNG sequence
here and then of course the location the
player shape so we're not gonna put into
game program thumbnails we're going to
put it into a our workspace yeah which
is over here and resources textures
sheets player
Shh doc pnj Renda and it is done so that
is um our player done after like 45
minutes of stuff here it is player
spreadsheet so we're gonna that's
actually gonna wrap up the after effects
tutorials we've got pretty much all the
stuff that we need and I'm just gonna
pop them into our game in the next
episode so next episode basically will
cover popping them into the game and
then the episode after that we're going
to well we'll see won't we
but anyway thanks for watching this
episode of game programming if you guys
liked it please hit like button again if
we hit 300 likes we will be releasing I
will be releasing two videos per day so
yeah hope you guys enjoyed this and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
you